[Musik]
zurück bei bild live an diesem
sonntagvormittag an dem der krieg in der
ukraine uns noch näher gekommen ist um
genau zu sein er ist nur noch rund 20
kilometer entfernt von der nato grenze
von der polnischen grenze das sind
bilder von einer militärbasis dort ganz
in der nähe auf der ukrainischen seite
also rund 20 kilometer entfernt von der
nato grenze dort sind heute acht
russische raketen eingeschlagen in den
ganz frühen morgenstunden auf diesem
gelände die erste bilanz von dort neun
tote und 57 verletzte schauen wir einmal
drauf auf die karte wo sich das alles
abgespielt hat also im westen der
ukraine ganz in der nähe von lemberg
einem ort der bisher noch als sicherer
hafen sozusagen in der ukraine galt dort
heute heftiger beschuss treffer auf
dieser militärbasis und jetzt gehen wir
genau dort hin zu meinem bild reporter
kollegen philipp potthoff village wo
haben die raketen heute wo sind die
raketen heute eingeschlagen die
russischen
ja wir haben heute kurz vor sechs uhr
morgens englischen werk das entsperren
explosionen gehört nun hat sich
herausgestellt dass acht russische
raketen auf einem stützpunkt circa 50
kilometer von berg nur 20 kilometer von
polen also von einer nato grenze
eingeschlagen sind hier diese straße ist
eine der vielen straßen gehen wie es mit
diesem militärstützpunkt führt wir waren
hier auch schon an einem eingang des
stützpunkts dort lässt man natürlich
niemanden rein die soldaten ihre sind
sehr nervös schauen dass sie alles
abwickeln wir versuchen natürlich
trotzdem so nah wie es geht dazu kommen
es ist auf jeden fall klar es gab viele
todesopfer sind mindestens neun
militärangehörige ums leben gekommen
über 50 wurden verwundet und ja das ist
eine neue dimension hier den bislang ist
die besten kleine eigentlich verschont
geblieben größtenteils verschont
geblieben von diesem krieg und jetzt
schlagen putins truppen auch jetzt tun
warum ist dieser punkt strategisch so
wichtig für die russischen
ja bis vor wenigen tagen erst
angekündigt dass erwarten lieferung
westliche waffenlieferung auch als
legitime militärische ziele betrachtet
und diese waffenlieferung die kommen
natürlich über die polnische grenze in
die ukraine und damit nimmt sie eben
auch alles was aus dem westen kommt ins
visier wir wissen natürlich nicht was
auf diesem stützpunkt war ob sich da
auch waffenlieferungen vielleicht ein
waffenlager befand auf jeden fall die
bilder die man von dort zieht die
beispielsweise in der new york times von
soldaten zugespielt wurden zwei absolut
schafften es kam vor wenigen minuten die
bildung auch dass dort ausländische
ausbilder
sein sollen auf dieser militärbasis hast
du darüber irgendwas rausfinden können
also das wäre ja auch noch mal eine
eskalation wenn dort möglicherweise
raketen auch auf diese jahr
nato-ausbilder möglicherweise gezielt
haben
ja ich habe darüber mit einem sprecher
des ukrainischen militärs gesprochen
allerdings wollte er uns das gegenüber
nicht bestätigen er hat nun klargestellt
dass wurden eine ausländer bei diesen
raketenangriffen verlegt verwundet es
ist kein ausländer zu schaden gekommen
das war die wichtigste botschaft denn
wenn hier ausländer tatsächlich
gestorben getötet oder eben verwundet
wurden das wäre dann noch mal eine neue
dimension
jetzt haben wir ja den vergangenen tagen
seit ausbruch des krieges gesehen wie
viel millionen menschen aus der ukraine
raus wollen aber viele flüchten die auch
innerhalb der ukraine und da war eben ja
lemberg bisher so eine art sichere hafen
noch in den vergangenen tagen was
bedeutet das jetzt für die menschen dort
muss er jetzt umso größere angst möglich
auf einige panik herrschen wenn die
raketeneinschläge immer dichter kommen
auch am lemberg heran
ja also wenn es tatsächlich eine
offensive in richtung lemberg könnte
dann befürchte ich eine massenpanik denn
in den vergangenen
zweieinhalb wochen war es in lemberg
ruhig es gab immer wieder mal raketen
beziehungsweise luftalarm aber es ist
eben nichts passiert es war eigentlich
so dass die menschen zum teil gar nicht
mehr hin gehört haben wenn luftalarm war
man hat es ein bisschen dran gewöhnt was
die einschläge trotzdem noch weit weg
sind das hat mich in den vergangenen
tagen geändert wir haben vorgestern zum
ersten mal objects über lemberg gesehen
kampfjet und immer wieder luft alle
angehört und heute früh eben diese ganz
entfernten explosionen gehört das macht
menschen natürlich klar lemberg muss
nicht verschont bleiben also diese
normalität im krieg an die man sich
gewöhnt hat in lemberg das ist trotz
allem in den ruhig bleibt liest seit
heute morgen erstmal dahin dank hat
bildreporter für den fiat auf der ort in
der nähe von lemberg auf dieser
militärbasis die heute früh in den ganz
frühen morgenstunden so schwer getroffen
wurde von acht russischen raketen
alleine dort neun tote und mehr als 50
verletzte danke für deine information
bild-reporter philippi adhoc